[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
brady quinn uh fox sports college
football nfl studio and game analyst and
uh he is uh one of the co-hosts two pros
and a cup of joe the show that precedes
hours with levar arrington and jonas
knox you can catch them on fox sports
radio weekdays six to nine a.m eastern
leading right into
our program brady joins us now from los
angeles he'll be in the fox studios not
on the road this week brady good morning
how's morale
uh morales fantastic although i'm a
little frustrated you know that check
swing last night i think it cost the uh
yeah you with your uh legendary baseball
career i'm sure that you knew the rule
of the check swing right
hey we did win a state championship in
division one there at dublin kaufman my
sophomore year um but no it was a bad
call uh i think there's some dodgers
fans who feel like this happened earlier
in the season to them i believe in this
uh in the series so they feel like it's
a little bit of payback uh but you know
if i always feel like if you're gonna
chalk it up to one thing
you're kind of missing the point you
obviously had other opportunities
throughout the course of the game yeah
the giants got shut down offensively the
entire series and that should be the
bigger picture they scored 10 runs in
five games
and you know the dodgers did what they
needed to do just enough to uh to
squeeze this out did you watch uh tom
brady in the uh buccaneers last night
of course yeah i mean you have a chance
to watch greatness every time he steps
on the field uh of course i was watching
okay but it looked like they did every
they should have won that game by
28 points something like that
yeah you allow the eagles to kind of
sneak back in um any concerns there
well you've got concerns about more i
think maybe they got conservative in the
second half with some of the play
calling that's a part of it but i think
defensively yeah i mean it's been well
documented that the bucks secondary is
banged up that's a pressure point teams
are going to keep pushing their finger
on and i think the other thing you're
starting to see too is more mobile
quarterbacks like jalen hurts we can
take off and run or extend plays
that's the biggest thing that i think
where defenses are at a disadvantage
it's just it's hard to replicate that in
practice it's hard to find someone who's
gonna be able to do what jalen hurts can
do or any other quarterback that falls
in that category of kyler murray and so
when you see it in live game reps it's
just
it's hard to be able to stop those plays
or you know the way we used to talk
about it when i was in seattle with
russell wilson is when that first play
breaks down a new play starts and
understanding the scramble rules and
understanding that kind of chemistry you
have with your quarterback it's tough
for any defense to stop they're already
reactive to begin with and then you put
you know in in a crazy play where guys
scrambling around playing backyard
football it's even tougher to stop but
you're going to have probably a record
number of quarterbacks rush for at least
500 yards this year
how dangerous is i mean i know it's
strategy but
17 games trying to keep your not
everybody can slide properly not
everybody gets out of bounds the right
way how concerned would you be that
there is this growing trend with these
younger quarterbacks but is that a good
thing
well i think it's a it's a good thing if
you're a fan of fantasy or offensive
football because i think it just puts
more pressure on defenses and it should
it should result in more points being
scored i think where your concern is is
long term are we ever going to see
you know a quarterback do what tom
brady's done that's gonna play the game
that way uh i would venture say no
so you know you hear guys like aaron
rodgers who go up and talk to joe burrow
after the game and say
get down protect yourself like the
pocket that's your safe haven um and
that's where i think it's not that these
players can't be successful doing it for
a period of time it's that you almost
have to be kind of like
lebron where early on his career you
know he's using his athleticism and how
dynamic he is and all those freakish
talents and then as he got older he sort
of developed more on the part of his
game where now he could play down the
post if he needs to his outside shooting
game his mid-range shot all those things
it's the same thing as a quarterback
he's gonna be running a lot early you
just have to develop that ability to use
it when you have to but only as a last
resort later in your career because
those hits add up on you but can lamar
jackson do that let's say five years
from now when we're assessing lamar
jackson is he still
putting pressure on the defenses rushing
for 800 900 000 yards
um i don't know that he's going to have
to at that point i mean i think you've
already seen him this year
start to take off and take that next
step as a passer you know as a pocket
passer and i think a lot's been made
about you know him as a passer which we
all knew when he came into the league
there was gonna be a growth curve but
the other thing you have to like look at
is who he's throwing to i think you look
at marquis brown for example or
hollywood brown he's continually come on
and gotten better too i think what he's
had out around them has has grown and
matured and got better at their craft so
that's played just as big of a part of
role in his development as a passer
to answer your question no i i don't
think he's going to need to do that at
that point time in his career down the
road but i think he's still going to
scare you with it you know he's still
going to do it
five to six seven times a game enough to
make you have to account for josh allen
you're comfortable with him running the
way he runs because he takes on contact
um i mean i'm comfortable now i don't
know if i'm comfortable two years from
now you know and watching him hurdle
guys i mean i thought i mean i'd pull my
groin at this point in time if i get my
leg spread apart too far so watching him
do that i'm saying
it's it's just it's not worth the risk
and i think it's hard to teach guys that
until they go through an injury
but you know i go and say that and then
you watch joe burl last week who
scrambles outside the pockets running
downfield and he ends up you know taking
a shot or unnecessary hit that he didn't
need to take and he just tore his acl so
um i think the hard thing and not to go
back to uh lamar but even talking about
josh allen is trying to change that
mentality in your head you know because
when you get out there especially as
you're as big as josh allen is or you've
been as successful as lamar jackson
making guys miss you're not thinking
about the any consequences or the
downside risk of it it's only until
after the fact you go oh maybe i need to
change my game a little bit and then you
have to ask yourself are they going to
be the same player if they take that out
of their game maybe not talking to brady
quinn fox sports college football and
nfl studio and game analyst i don't know
what happened maybe jimmy johnson opened
the door this weekend on fox sports the
pregame show where he said he would take
justin herbert over patrick mahomes and
then all of a sudden it became a topic
of conversation this week on the
different shows
i'll put that question to you would you
take justin herbert over patrick mahomes
right now
i wouldn't right now i think patrick has
already been proven in this league and
the the types of like when i look at the
two as passers okay not not throwers
passers
meaning the ability to articulate their
arm to make whatever throw they need to
or shape a throw to whatever way they
need to i think patrick is still more
talented in that respect um now don't
get me wrong justin herbert has a
howitzer for an arm and his accuracy
downfield especially like 15 yards plus
outside the numbers it might be the best
in the league right now
but as far as the touch throws and
shaping throws and articulating his arm
he doesn't have that quite as much as
patrick does
and and so i think you could put patrick
on a bunch of different teams in the nfl
and he could probably survive and be
able to spit the football out
i i think justin found himself in a
really good situation that staff that's
playing to his strengths both last year
you saw that in this year um their
offensive line play doesn't get enough
credit for sean slater's studs so
there's a lot of those working parts you
know mahomes is is playing for a team
right now that's got a defense that's
giving up you know yards per play
equivalent to the greatest show on turf
i mean literally they're giving up 7.1
yards per play
the rams back in the day used to get
seven yards per play so it's like every
time the chiefs walk on the field
they're playing the greatest show on
turf it's tough to go up that against
that as a quarterback but i don't know
how this became open season on patrick
mahomes because it feels like that like
the chiefs are vulnerable
um
it it just feels like you know maybe
people should realize what patrick
mahomes has been trying to keep together
there because the chiefs haven't had an
impressive defense it's just that
offense kind of overshadows and cleans
up all the blemishes here but when i and
i love justin herbert he's just not at
patrick mahomes level right now and
that's nice yeah it's not a knock on him
i if i said you can have uh josh allen
or patrick mahomes
who are you taking
um gosh i mean i probably still take
patrick but that one's getting closer
and closer being pretty questionable
because because josh does have those
traits of
being able to throw a little bit sidearm
being able to kind of roll to his left
and just kind of twist his upper body to
make those throws
and i think he's more effective as a
runner so
you know that's a tough one because i
think we've seen josh
um slowly kind of build to this where
right now you'd probably say he's the
mvp of the league delays played
or tom brady
or tom brady he said he could i mean
he said he can play another 10 years he
said he probably wouldn't
why
why why would brady not contin now he
says he you know he once spent time with
his family and all those things i
understand that right but right right do
you think he could play
five more six until he's 50.
i i don't know why you think he couldn't
i mean one of the most impressive things
was when you go back and look at that
first touchdown pass antonio brown
just the way he still slides and moves
in the pocket like that's all he needs
to do yeah i remember playing for jim
zorn and him saying to me he's like you
don't have to be the fastest or quickest
guy in the pocket you just have to be
sudden and it reminds me of like all
those older boxers that they don't have
like what they used to have as far as
quickness the ability to move but they
just have to be sudden enough to make a
guy miss and then deliver the throw and
so he's still got that i i think if he
still has the o-line and the situation
of playmakers around him like he has
yeah he could play as long as he needs
to and i don't i don't know maybe
there's something that tv 12 method like
maybe we need to give more credit to
alex guerrero and the the people who are
involved because it seems to be working
for everyone who works with those guys
well maybe you were too muscle-bound
when you worked out for john gruden
coming out of notre dame
i remember you telling us the story this
is like five years ago but yeah he
thought you were too muscle-bound
he was very enamored with my traps at
that point which i'm not sure wait not
sure why did you did he verbalize that
comfortable did he say hey yeah he had a
laser pointer we had a laser pointer so
he was up there and we were going
through it and he was like pointed out
and the weird thing was like i actually
see myself without a shirt on often
um but i never felt more awkward or
uncomfortable sitting in that moment
while he's like using the laser pointer
to point out wait you guys
he's got a picture of you with your
shirt off
it was well it was from the combine yeah
you know so you go up there and you're
skippies and you know they they take a
photo of you which like tom brady's is
probably the most famous like everyone's
seen yeah uh and the one of me you know
at that point you know i obviously
worked out hard you know i got two
parents where i got great genetics so it
comes maybe a little easier for me but
he's pointing all this stuff down he's
like i don't need a guy who looks like
this and all this stuff and then you
know he showed another quarterback who
tended to be a little heavier set he's
like i don't want this either
and then he showed another quarterback
he's like i want this guy this guy looks
like i can go out and have a beer with
him and i was just like
all right like i'm not sure what you
want me to say to this so i i mean we
want to go grab a beer now or like look
we're gonna go work like what are we
doing so who were those other two
quarterbacks
um jamarcus russell was the other one um
who obviously you know i trained with
jamarcus pre-draft
and you know i'll tell you this much i
mean he was uber talented i you know you
look at josh allen justin herbert patch
bones all the arms strong arms i've
never seen an arm like his like i
remember it was me and him who went the
first round i was i was watching him
before i was like well good god he's
going to go before me i don't have the
ability to throw a ball like that
but he was you know he didn't work out
very hard i mean i was there often and
trust me if he would have been there i
would have seen him and i very rarely
ever saw him there in preparation for
all of that
um but he was the one quarterback then
charlie frye was the other quarterback
didn't gruden draft charlie fry
uh i can't recall if he drinks well i
don't know charlie got drafted to
cleveland but bruce grackowski
so bruce gracowski was on so this was
all like a film like a like we were
watching like a cut up he had
and it opened up with like him showing
some cheerleaders or dancing and i was
like what the hell is this and then he
had like a cheetah that was like jumping
on a gazelle and like tearing it apart
and i was like all right that's kind of
cool i still don't know what this has to
do with football
and then he kind of went through the
whole combine photos and then he started
showing some like he showed some bad
plays like bruce gracowski and like you
know what we'd be looking at here all
this stuff and this is what i need and
then he started going through like the
college tape but it was like he was
famous for that you know he's famous for
the film sessions all the cut up so but
that was back when he was the head coach
at tampa
like your head has to be spinning
like you're thinking wait what am i
getting myself like what what does he
think i'm any good
well if he talks he talks you up like we
were out there because then he brought
in two wide receivers and then i had a
wide receiver in running back who were
catching for me before that workout
and so he would talk you up and he was
indeed the whole time doing drills and
he was a ton of fun to work with
but you know and after he kind of puts
your arm around he's like i'm going to
come up and draft you we're going to
come get you and all this stuff and you
don't know you've never been through it
before so you know the cynic in me is
like yeah okay like we'll see when that
day comes but the other side of me are
like how cool would that be you get to
play for this guy every single day
um and obviously with everything that's
come out of late you know it's it's sad
to see that behind closed doors that's
how he's talk or that's how he was
handling things
um
but you know
again i mean that whole that whole
experience was just i guess head
spinning was one of those the best way
to put it before i let you go this
oklahoma situation is is really
interesting with spencer rattler who a
lot of people thought heisman trophy and
you know my my point was maybe for maybe
first overall pick right yeah and i kept
saying watch him play a game don't watch
the highlights because he is a highlight
but watch him he got benched last year
and i he's not consistent and you know
you got lincoln riley he can cover up a
lot of things now you've got a situation
where if you're spencer rattler and you
look and you see the future is out there
on the field and it's not you
what do you do if you're spencer rattler
at oklahoma
it's such a tough decision because if he
feels like he's not going to be the guy
there's still so much football left to
be played like i think the biggest
mistake he can make right now is making
an irrational decision
and deciding to transfer right away like
we've already seen that in certain cases
like we've already seen guys who have
done that this season
um and i think that's a bad look because
one you don't know if caleb williams is
athletic as he is if he gets injured
your team needs you you're right back in
there so that's the first thing
the next thing is you know
he's draft eligible like does he look at
this quarterback class and go i'm gonna
prove to people that like yeah i haven't
played my best necessarily or i'm not at
my best but they can draft me and they
can help me get there because he is
talented i mean no one's going to deny
his arm strength ability to throw off
platform all those things but he needs a
lot of experience and more work
um he could look at other situations
that are out there right now you know he
might be looking at a place like georgia
and say i'd like to go in there behind
that offensive line with those
playmakers you know not have to worry
about winning a shootout with that
defense and go play there or go play
anywhere else and try to transfer right
that's always a part of it
my concern is
that the parents
direct because at this age like even
though you're a young man and you have
your desires and goals and what you want
to do
the parents sometimes start to lean in
on that too and they start to shape it
that could be good and bad and so like i
don't know his personal situation with
his family
but that also is a factor in all of this
and that's where i wonder you know if
the parents especially just having
coached high school kids now knowing how
overbearing they can be
if they start weighing in on that you
know hey let's get somewhere else right
now let's go somewhere else let's move
on this isn't a good place for you um
that's the hard thing because for the
young man he's always identified himself
as a quarterback
and when that's taken away from you and
you get put on the bench
it shocks you i mean it really wrecks
your entire world and so you could be in
a tough headspace and you can let anyone
talk you into anything at that point in
time
so hopefully he can let his emotions
pass
and and they can get kind of some more
clarity of what their plan is moving
forward depending on how the season goes
have a great weekend tell the guys we
said hello and have fun thank you brady
we'll talk to you next week thank you
all right that's brady quinn fox sports
college and nfl studio and game analyst